what is up guys before this video get
started I want to give a huge shout out
to clam for doing this for me he's one
of my friends and he recorded this for
me so we could show you guys how much
money you can make with these new rocks
so shout out to him and let's get
started into the video
[Music]
[Applause]
so we will be mining rue nitrox in the
new twos our city for an hour and the
only requirement is eighty-five mining
and you also need to be able to show
your fire cape to the guide the entrance
in order to get in so in this mining
spot there are three rune ight rocks and
they are all protected so this is a
great spot to mine Runet rocks if you
have 85 mining so it takes about 30
seconds to get one rune eye or and I
will come back when I have a full
inventory alright we're almost out of
full inventory alright there's one and
it took about 18 minutes exactly to get
one full inventory
you
and so you just run up to the bank
that's up here to the north
you
so one inventory is about 317 K
took about 18 minutes
so just go ahead and put it in your bank
and then run back to the spot and start
mining again so the hour is almost up we
have about 30 seconds let's see what we
can get in this last 30 seconds
hopefully we can mine in two ores let's
see
you
there's one all right 20 seconds let's
go
you
all right perfect
all right so the hour is up so I will go
to the grand exchange and I will show
you guys how much you made in one hour
all right so we're at the GE now and
we'll go ahead and sell them we'll put
them in for eleven thousand three
hundred and sixty and I'll come back
when those sell all right it took about
five minutes to sell and we made 1
million 67,000 in an hour so that is
really good money if you have 85 mining
I highly recommend that you go to this
new mining spot because it has three
rocks and you don't have to go to PvP
world additionally if you have the
prospector equipment you can get 12 K
experience per hour and if you don't
have the prospector it's about a 1 K
loss experience per hour but I do
recommend you have it
alright guys again shout out to clams
and thanks for watching guys and stay
tuned for my next video
[Music]